[Musique]
la FRCA le département de La Réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la Réunion vous
présente terre
[Musique]
d'ici 3 ans après le lancement de ce
programme innovant chercheurs et
arboriculteurs rrouve lors d'un
séminaire pour faire le point sur
l'avancement du projet biopyo biophyo M
c'est un projet qui est mené bah par
plusieurs organismes de l'État et
régionaux de manière à diminuer voire à
réduire complètement l'utilisation
d'insecticides dans les champs de
Manguer associé au sirad une dizaine de
partenaires du monde agricole parmi
lesquels la Chambre d'Agriculture la
ropefel l'armée flore ou encore la
FDGDON travaille au développement de ces
techniques visant à produire des mangues
sans insecticides en favorisant la
biodiversité dans les vergers un projet
qui visait à tester à confronter sur le
terrain confronter aux réalités du
terrain le le les principes de
l'agroécologie et notamment de la
protection agroécologique des cultures
la protection agroécologique des
cultures notamment ici celle des
manguiers s'appuie sur la lutte
biologique de conservation l'objectif
est de préserver les insectes utiles en
favorisant la biodiversité végétale en
apportant ainsi des services au
fonctionnement du verger les insectes
auxiliaires constiue alors une
biodiversité fonctionnelle c'est-à-dire
l'impact positif de pratique
agroécologique où on supprime les
traitement insecticid où l'on insère des
couvertures végétales permanentes au sol
par exemple sur les les les insectes
utiles je pour caricaturer les insectes
utiles qui peuvent être des des
prédateurs qui mangent par exemple des
ravageurs des parasitoïdes des par paras
qui qui qui vivent au dépend de de
ravageurs ou ouou des pollinisateurs qui
simplement participent à la à la
production en présentant à cette
occasion les résultats de leurs travaux
de recherche les participants à ce
séminaire ont bien montré toute
l'importance de préserver et de
développer la biodiversité dans les
systèmes agricoles tant qu'on utilisera
des pesticides on aura du mal à voir la
biodiversité et de savoir laquelle il
faut protéger je dirais le principal
enseignement c'est c'est qu'il y a pas
une solution toute faite pour t les
systèmes qui existent dans ce monde et
en particulier même au sein de la
Réunion hein je pense que chaque
agriculteur a son système et ses ses
cultures et et son microclimat qui font
que la biodiversité est différente et à
mon avis un enjeu de la de la recherche
mais aussi du développement et de tous
les praticiens sont de de vouloir
développer des outils pour essayer de
mieux piloter et suivre cette
biodiversité pour sélectionner les
espèces qui leur sont les plus
bénéfiques
[Musique]
après les diverses présentation des
résultats de recherche en salle place à
la pratique sur le terrain avec des
visites de vergers agriculteurs et
chercheurs peuvent ainsi discuter et
échanger directement de l'expérience des
uns et des attentes des autres sur le
projet biofyo un projet qui vise à
produire des mangues sans insecticides
ici par exemple ils assistent à la
présentation d'un nouveau type de piège
destiné à lutter contre la mouche des
fruits donc les mouches sont attirées
donc au niveau des des des trous qui
sont fixés donc aux extrémités donc
ensuite il y a l'attractif donc l'
sexuel donc les mouches quand elles sont
emprisonnées donc elles sont attirées
ensuite donc par la lumière donc qui est
au-dessus du couvercle et donc comme sur
le couvercle il y a un insecticide s
forme de gel de la deltaamétrine donc au
contact les insectes donc meurent et
restent dans le bas du CNE ce dispositif
de lutte sélective est opérationnel
pendant 4 mois assurant ainsi une
protection du verger jusqu'à la récolte
des fruits pour plus d'efficacité encore
ces pièges à mouche doivent être
installés à une densité de 80 par
hectare une solution intéressante pour
les producteurs de mangue oui ça paraît
intéressant déjà ça permet de
moin d'intervention diminution desû de
production ça para intéressant après il
faut le vérifier à la prochaine saison
s'il y a pas de cyclone c'est vrai que
nous depuis ces dernières années on a
beaucoup d'attaqu de de mouche et c'est
ma bête noire quoi de la production
c'est le plus important il faut
surveiller énormément donc l'année
dernière j'ai testé les
pièges je suis satisfaite mais avec le
cyclone qui est arrivé au mois de
janvier on peut pas dire si l'efficacité
faut le tester à nouveau C année juste à
côté un atelier d'identification permet
aux arbculteurs de reconnaître les
insectes utiles dé nuuisibles comme ici
par exemple cette microgêe ça peut être
des espèces qui sont très petites très
diversifié donc 300 espèces dans les
dans l'ensemble des vergers de Mang
qu'on a suivi dans le cadre du projet
biofyo et de 146 jour différents donc
c'est vraiment encore augment la
biodiversité avec les pratiques
agroécologiques on va vraiment avoir une
une augmentation de la biodiversité on
l'a vu tout au long du projet biophyo et
c'est important pour les planteurs c'est
important qu'on transmette aux planteurs
les connaissances acquises pour que sur
le terrain ils puissent faire la part
entre les bons et les mauvais ça permet
aux agriculteurs d'être formés de
reconnaître la punaise mais aussi à nous
de de savoir bah le ressenti et les
difficultés qu'elles peuvent qu'ils ont
à reconnaître ces insectes
là
[Musique]